this was a day that millions watched but
that here they witnessed
a spot in the very front row of history
that meant for some a cold night under
the flags
we've just laid yeah we've slept
underneath the union jack that was the
reason
it was amazing but the community spirit
with everybody just on another level
it's a pivotal moment in this
this nation's history children will be
studying this for many many years to
come
and this felt like a moment people
wanted to share
to see
to be part of
and to pass on
my daughter's molly she's seven years
old and i just think and she'll remember
this it'll be a momentous occasion for
forever you know when she's got children
of her own she can say you know i was at
the queen's funeral my dad always said
that he remembered the sort of the
carnation and stuff and then like that
was like one of his best days out and
obviously this is not you know sort of a
joyful day but i just think we
definitely will remember it i just think
it's really important that we came
in other parts of london
like hyde park the funeral service
itself was broadcast on big screens
[Music]
but here on the mall it was just the
sound
and it was deeply moving
people that we've spoken to said that
they didn't really know what to expect
from being down here they just wanted to
be part of what was happening and as
soon as this service started being
broadcast it's been absolute silence
people not really looking on their
phones at the funeral just at
westminster abbey but just standing here
listening and being part of this
extraordinary moment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign some told us they cried for the
queen
some for the memories her loss invoked
my mum passed away last year
and she loved the queen and julie
lost your mum as well i did a few years
ago and i was in the military left last
november retired so i think with our
military background we just felt we
really wanted to be here today as well
for the bus for the boss
and then that final goodbye
finally came
in an event where every single move has
been choreographed almost to the minute
it's those little moments the
spontaneous rounds of applause which
have turned something so public into
something which actually feels really
personal
i don't think you'll ever forget this
moment where you were what you saw and
who you were with and how you felt about
it so make sure you go and be able to
rest in peace
this is a place that has marked many
royal moments
none though quite like this
sad of
course
but unforgettable
caterina for totsi sky news the man
[Music]